minute and second were angle
measurements before they were time
measurements we all know there's 360
degrees in a circle right well the
ancient Babylonians had smaller
increments than degrees they were called
the arc minute and the arc second we
still use them today 1 60th of a degree
was called an arc minute because it was
a minute piece of a degree it's not a
coincidence that these two words are
spelled the same and our second is 1
60th of an arc minute because it was the
second level of minute pieces these
words only started to be used for time
more recently when our clocks got
precise enough to measure minute pieces
of an hour it's an analogy language is
wild